and here we are with another guest of
the tournament alexander onishuk
ukrainian american grandmaster you were
in different times ukrainian champion
american champion played for both
countries for the national teams
alexander welcome to the grand tour how
is it to be here
thank you thank you anastasia um now
it's great to be here thank you for
inviting me it's great to see this event
like in person it's been a while i've
been to such big tournaments on this one
and uh especially um
like uh
not in the us because in the us
obviously i
i attend some tournaments in saint louis
but this one is uh you know just an
amazing tournament
uh with lots of great players it's nice
to
follow the tournament and many
interesting games many decisive games
and uh yeah i'm glad to be here who was
the most impressive player so far i mean
for you which games did you follow with
with interest
well i mean you know i should say all of
them obviously but um
of course i'm rooting for american
players and i'm glad to see that wesley
saw is leading
the tournament with the left
yeah i hope one of the us players will
win uh this event
you you were the one who took part also
in this fundraising event for ukraine
what were your impressions what what do
you think about such events
i think it was a great event and the
main thanks to
uh the main sponsor superbad and
obviously everyone who attended the
event
uh it was great uh to
meet all these people i have talked to
some of them next day and uh they were
telling us stories like their personal
stories
how they support ukraine ukrainian
people and quite frankly you know being
here in romania and meeting
uh so many people that uh you know do
their best helping refugees
um helping ukraine ukrainians uh it's
it's very important for me to kind of
meet these people and thank them
uh alexander how did your life changed
in the way after the war started
because of course we know that you keep
ukrainian
you reality you have ukrainian relatives
in ukraine and france yeah uh well it
has changed a lot i should say um
as you know i'm originally from crimea
and
i still
have some friends there i used to have
more friends in crimea and
overall i should say but uh
yeah my life has also changed a little
bit
of course
i started being more involved
once the award started and uh
helping helping philippine ukraine
also taking part a part in some events
in my hometown
we have a small ukrainian community and
i mean americans they support ukraine so
much and
you know we ukrainians living in the u.s
we are i'm very grateful to everyone who
you know who puts a flag outside of
their house or just donates the money
and uh
it has happened from day one and uh
i think it's very important and very
important for the us and the important
of course for ukraine to have such a
support in the in in america
thank you very much alexander and
welcome once again to grand chester and
we hope to see you once again here as i
know that you are going to poland as
well